are you a fan of wrestling  what about developer suit of 51 well  I've got some great news I'm Tony this  is a GameSpot news update and be sure to  subscribe for all the latest on the  hottest wrestling games and it doesn't  get much hotter than fire pro wrestling  a series suda51 worked on in his early  development days now it's coming back  with the same grapple focused wrestling  that made it famous back in the 90s  you'll also be able to create your own  wrestler and ring play online and tweak  the rules to create crazy custom matches  for the record the last title in the  series was 2012's fire Pro Wrestling on  Xbox Live Arcade Fire Pro Wrestling was  just announced but it's coming to steam  early access sometime in 2017 for more  wrestling talk head over to our GameSpot  universe channel to stay up to date on  all the happenings in the WWE and for  all the latest wrestling game news  you're already in the right place  you  [Music]